ça m'offusque de voir que certains
s'offusent que pas en fait tout le monde
devrait être révolté par ça par la
violence après et les policiers
c'est-à-dire que pour répondre à un
certain nombre de
d'exactions on a le droit de faire usage
de la force de manière proportionnée de
manière responsable on a un certain
nombre d'outils des moyens de force
intermédiaires comment quand on les
utilise hier on a utilisé par exemple
l'engin lanceur d'eau lanceur lanceur
d'eau ça ne tue pas ça ne blesse pas et
donc on a ces outils là et on a le droit
de le faire donc c'est pas la même chose
qui viennent ici aussi des des des pères
de famille des maires de famille qui me
disent on veut manifester tranquillement
et on se fait booster on se fait
bousculé on se fait attaquer on se fait
on a peur maintenant d'aller manifester
alors que on veut manifester contre
cette réforme des retraites on a peur
d'y aller parce que on a peur de ce qui
va nous tomber dessus mais ils ont
raison quand on voit le pré cortège il y
avait ça rien c'est toute la faute des
des Black Blocs bien sûr comme je vous
dis la plupart des manifestations elles
se passent bien mais quand vous avez
1500 à 2000 élément radicaux dans un
pré-corpège qui bloque tout qui commence
à commettre des exactions bien sûr que
moi personnellement j'irai pas avec un
avec un enfant dans ce type de
manifestation c'est dangereux et donc je
comprends les familles qui sont qui sont
inquiète dans ce cadre-là après une fois
de plus il y en a plein qui se qui se
passent bien et et moi j'aurais un seul
mot pour ceux qui veulent qui veulent
manifester c'est faites attention à vous
et si vous voyez des éléments radicaux
dissociez-vous de ces de ces groupes là
mettez-vous pas en danger parce que
certains exercent des violences vous
êtes donc d'accord avec le ministre
ministre de l'intérieur c'est mon boss
qui est plutôt
avec moi il a de la chance que moi ils
sont pas
à sa manière avec une vision très
politique moi je suis additionnelle moi
je préfère les mecs qui disent les
choses voilà je vous le dis et Gérald
Darmanin au moins il dit des choses et
moi je suis fonctionnaire donc voilà le
jour le ministre part je resterai
fonctionnaire dans ce ministère mais
nous quand on le vit sur le terrain moi
j'étais sur le terrain il y a pas si
longtemps je me suis pris une fois un 31
décembre une un projectile sur le casque
quand j'étais en maintien de l'ordre sur
les Champs-Élysées c'est horrible ça
vous sonne et vous êtes vous n'êtes pas
bien pendant longtemps c'est ce qu'on
vit sur le terrain a réagi le maintien
de l'ordre hier a tourné une fois de
plus à une absurde violence générale
Darmanin on est 100% responsable c'est
pourquoi il veut reporter sa
responsabilité sur les autres les
policiers devraient se méfier d'un chef
aussi lamentable maintenant je suis pas
d'accord on peut pas être d'accord avec
ça quand on est présent il y avait hier
5000 policiers et gendarmes sur la
manifestation quand on a vécu ce qu'ils
ont vécu on peut pas être d'accord avec
ça
pour vous Géraldine vous êtes d'accord
avec le ministre de l'Intérieur moi je
suis d'accord avec Monsieur Darmanin et
je trouve que encore une fois Monsieur
Mélenchon est irresponsable quand il
parle de la police
alors il y a une image qui au départ
était présentée comme des violences de
manifestants contre des policiers
pourtant ce sont les forces de l'ordre
elles-mêmes qui se serait lancée une
grenade dessus on va voir cette image
regardez
c'est des choses qui arrivent
malheureusement les grenades il y a
une méthode d'ouverture de la grenade il
y a des méthodes de lancer et puis des
fois il peut y avoir des accidents
malheureusement donc voilà je sais pas
exactement ce qui s'est passé dans le
détail mais c'est des choses
malheureusement qui que j'ai vécues sur
le terrain qui peuvent arriver et voilà
les collègues ont eu le bon réflexe
d'évacuer rapidement la personne je vous
ai fait un petit peu réagir sur les
manifestants je voudrais avoir des deux
images qui sont importantes du côté des
manifestants des noms plusieurs
personnes donc blessées ou mutiler lors
de cette journée de manifestation en
dernier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et bien sûr que c'est violent quand
c'est violent il y a du sang il y a des
larmes il y a des blessures
qui ont l'air pacifistes on sait pas il
a des lunettes de piscine donc
on a pas on n'a pas quand il y a des gaz
lacrylos on a le droit mais non mais non
mais là là là là dessus c'est quoi c'est
compliqué pour les forces de l'ordre de
nous on était on essaie toujours d'être
proportionné par rapport à à ce qu'on
reçoit en termes de projectile en terme
d'offensive on a une fois de plus des
armes pour se faire mais une arme c'est
pas anodin en fait une connerie je sais
pas anodin bien sûr bien sûr il met des
lunettes parce qu'il sait très bien
qu'il y a des gaz il y a des trucs
c'est pareil de temps en temps
malheureusement il peut y avoir des
personnes qui ont des mains arrachées
mais pourquoi elles ont démarché c'est
souvent parce qu'elles ont porté la main
alors on va regarder c'est la grenade